[Applause]
[Music]
Jane Fonda is known for hitting her Mark
but not like this
[Music]
the legendary actress going viral for
this moment throwing an award at a
winning director oh yes I'm very aware
it all went down as the 85 year old
actress presented the Palm Door award to
French director Justine Tria at the
Cannes Film Festival
but after accepting the honor Justine
forgot to take her scrolled certificate
with her so Jane took matters into her
own hands
[Music]
yep she Chucks it and hits Justine's
back
Vance praised the Move online one
tweeting damn good throw and another
writing Bravo Jane Fonda respect I think
you have to be confident and know who
you are Jean's viral moment in France
comes after she made waves in Italy on
the big screen
rum is a great walking City
what did he say the older The Vines the
sweeter the fruit oh yes we still got it
she's fresh off a press tour for the
Roman Holiday themed book club the next
chapter we were in this magical place
and you were with people who would tell
you the truth about who you are and know
how much all this meant to you that was
the moderate amount of alcohol
Spritz is the key and also we were
filming at the historic iconic China
you know where all those great Fellini
movies and I mean it was just it was
that was magical too yeah Jane and her
co-stars had the time of their life in
Italy and if they have it their way
there are more Adventures to come what
about retirement is this a thing that
you ever even before comes into your
life or you're just like I'm gonna keep
doing this till I don't know when and do
what golf yeah
it's not a word that we use it shouldn't
be right if you're having this much fun
or at least at least it's you know
working keeps you alive the great thing
about acting is that you're invited to
come and become another person and you
have to do enter that other person with
great empathy so it expands you
and I mean it's just such a challenge to
find who is this person that I'm
supposed to be in what was she like as a
child and all those kinds I find great
joy in doing that kind of character
exploration me too the ultimate puzzle
yeah
foreign